hi everyone my name is Christine and I'm
a front-end web developer I actually
just started programming six months ago
and I found my first deaf job about
three months so now I've been a web
developer for about three to four months
now and I really love it
so this talk I'm just gonna give a
little background about myself and my
interest in coding and also how what I
did to weigh in my first job so I
graduated from the University of
Oklahoma about 4 years ago with the
political science degree and I didn't
really know what exactly to do with a
political science degree I was confused
and lost and so I decided that I wanted
to be a lawyer and be a makeup artist be
other different things I had so many
different hobbies that I wanted to do
and I contemplated thought about it and
I realized that those are the type of
jobs that I might not be interested in
the long run and so I got into coding
when I landed my first job in the
marketing field and I worked with HTML
templates and WYSIWYG and a lot of the
stuff that I did before was mainly just
coding the tables inside the WYSIWYG
very simple stuff and I realized that I
wanted to do more in life I didn't want
to stay at my old job because you know I
just feel like I will plateau quickly so
I looked around for different types of
classes I looked into getting a computer
science degree but I realized that you
don't really need a computer science
degree to do web development and I
really like web development because I
like art and design so I feel like that
would be something I'm good at
so I looked around online for some
classes and a lot of the classes were
really expensive one class to learn
JavaScript was about 2 grand that I saw
and so I was like you know I feel like I
could find
something else you know maybe try
different routes some other classes that
may be cheaper and then I saw okay
coders which is where I met Carson he
was one of my instructors ok coders and
had helped me a lot throughout my
journey so I just and say Thank You
Carson very very much so I found it ok
coders and it's basically a six-month
module or six modules six months long
bootcamp class every Saturday and you
learn everything about web development
starting with beginning with HTML CSS
you learn how to use your command line
you learn how to use your github where
you push all your files and into github
and then also JavaScript libraries which
is really really important if you're
looking to be a front-end developer so
yeah i attended bootcamp for about six
months and a lot of the work I had to
code after practice coding every single
day and get better the classes were only
four hours long every week and I knew
that you have to put extra work into you
have to put in the extra work outside of
class so you know I studied a lot I read
all my documentation that's probably the
most important thing is reading your
documentation starting out and that's
what I did I use all my online resources
I practice on Codecademy udemy lynda.com
those are great if you want to get into
coding those are great online resources
to take and practice on I also asked a
lot of help from people I joined tech
Lahoma met a lot of the great developers
in the community and just getting advice
from people or people who have
experience in this type of curve really
helped me love being a developer even
more the excitement of you know seeing
people creating so many cool things it
sorry but creating a lot of cool things
it's just
amazing and and I think that's why we
all want to be developers is that we
want to create something and build
something of our own
and so anyways I practice a lot and then
I was also looking for a job at the same
time knowing that I'm probably not
qualified but I gave it a shot anyways I
just kept trying and I attended job
fairs and brushed up my resume I created
a portfolio I created a lot of side
projects and pushed everything to my
github to show that I put in a lot of
work you know even if I know my code
wasn't that great I just pushed
everything into my github and then
finally got my first dev job at a
marketing company who's willing to take
this opportunity opportunity on me even
though they know that I'm probably I'm
still really new and not fully qualified
I got the job and I was really excited
got a little content and about two weeks
ago I actually almost lost my job
because I wasn't practicing enough
outside of work and that's the most
important things that I want to tell you
guys starting out as a developer if you
have not much or no prior programming
experience you have to practice even
when you get the job you have to
practice outside of work and I just I
got to content I was too happy and I
relaxed and then you know I was in a
very tough spot where they said that I
need to improve or it just won't work
out and I was given two weeks to show
improvement at my job and I did it and
it was very it was a lot of work I just
whatever I did at work I showed them and
I had better communication with my
senior developers that's also one
important thing that you guys have to
know is communication with your fellow
developers that was one thing that I
didn't do very well I
I was the type of person that I wanted
to learn everything my front-end skills
weren't even that great and I wanted to
learn to do PHP and sequel and all the
backend and I took in work I don't even
know what I was coding they gave me
pitch me and sequel and I'm just sitting
here trying to figure it out when I
realized that sometimes you have to say
no when you're not ready for something
you have to say no and so I was honest
to them and said hey I'm not ready for
this yet and I need to practice on my
front-end skills and that's what I did
so when you get your new job when you
get your developer job make sure you are
fluent with all your languages before
jumping into something else
for me I just I just wanted to learn
everything I couldn't say no because I
was scared to say no I wanted I wanted
to learn everything and be good at
everything and sometimes you know it's
you have to take it one step at a time
I thought being a developer meanings you
have to know you know react you have to
know angular even though at my job we
use jQuery like I wanted to learn react
and angular I want to do all these
things but I know I have to take it one
step at a time and that's the important
thing
another thing is besides that is getting
feedback from your senior devs and you
know just your fellow developers that
you're working with especially when
you're new getting feedback is great
knowing your work process like how
you're doing always ask them like how am
i doing do you think I'm doing okay
because I know everyone has their own
different techniques so it's best to
just have a good communication and
getting feedback from your peers and
another one is never stop practicing
always keep learning I'm still in the
learning process right now I mean a
couple of weeks ago I was here trying to
debug a bootstrap carousel and I felt
embarrassed debugging a bootstrap care
so because I'm like well this is so
simple like why can't I get it but I
learned that it's still a learning
process for me I'm still I'm still
learning I just
continue to grow and sometimes it's okay
to ask for help even something so simple
like bootstrap carousel or learning how
to use bootstrap it's never embarrassing
to ask questions because you actually
learn from asking questions just don't
ask the same questions over and over ask
and absorb that's the most important
thing but yeah and then another thing is
oh yeah this is probably important too
but I try to use the same IDs as your
fellow developers I know we all have you
know a preference that we use like I
like visual studio code that's just my
preference but I know like at my job and
stuff we use phpstorm or like Adam and
stuff like that I just think it's you
don't you don't have to do it but I
think it helps with the workflow and the
process when you use the same IDE as
your fellow peers that usually helps a
lot and then another tip is when you get
your first project it's always good to
whiteboard it out draw a map of how
you're going to build your website you
know have an idea before you actually
start coding that was my mistake too is
I didn't really have an idea and so I
kind of just start coding random things
when you have to wipe word it out you
have to talk to your boss don't try to
take initiative with anything no well
don't try to take initiative with
everything beside not letting your
fellow developers know always always try
to wipe board it up and then another
thing is little loss eye projects if you
have anything you're interested in
building do it after work hours you know
take the weekend off don't go out with
your friends like if you have to improve
you have to just start practicing more
and more build something cool like I
want to eventually build an app but
another thing is don't be afraid to try
new things
code something different don't code the
same thing over and over right now since
I still pretty new I am practicing on
building my jQuery Maps I built a couple
Maps before and but I'm still practicing
not that great with the map I'm learning
how to style maps with JavaScript so
build something new try something new at
least every single week and you'll get
better and just learn that way
but yeah it's um so that's all I really
have with the tips and advice and my
story is just really practicing using
your online resources talk to your peers
also have good communication with your
boss when finding a job push yourself
out there join organizations that's what
I did
you know I joined tech Lahoma I joined
free code camp I talked with my
instructors that's the most important
thing it's just communicating with
fellow developers that could give you
really good advice and also don't take
criticism as an insult
always take criticism as something you
can prove and learn from and that's the
most important thing is and then yeah
getting feedback beside projects
draw a map yeah that's really all that I
have I know it's kind of short but if
anyone has any questions or yeah well my
interview was actually very short I
didn't really take a test or anything I
know some companies require you to take
a test I actually took a test a couple
weeks before that with an HR recruiter
when I was trying to find a job just
testing my JavaScript and I did all
right on that but they didn't hire me on
another company I saw that I was very
motivated to learn and try new things
and also they liked the fact that I'm a
previous job I wore many hats like I did
all the digital content at my job and I
was lucky enough because the company I
work for really needed someone and so I
got the job as a web developer yeah
that's I just told him my experience and
everything gave him my portfolio and
yeah there
the most useful thing that I did was
mainly reading my documentation in the
beginning oh I can't I can't say this
enough but reading your documentation is
so so important that's what I spent my
time doing outside of work now it's just
reading through everything carefully and
even though I was in boot camp class I
miss like the little things here and
there because I was trying to code out
my portfolio but even when I coded out
it still wasn't it wasn't good I did a
lot of what I did was I would always
inspect where I click inspect in my
console and then just go in there in a
debug but when you actually read your
documentation clearly and thoroughly it
really helps you to understand what
you're doing a lot more so I can just
code it out now fluently rather than
having to inspect all the time and so I
did that and then just practice a lot
online outside of work that was probably
the most useful things that I did as a
developer
well it's like so like on bootstrap
saying you know it gives you all the
elements and stuff so they have your
columns how to build bootstrap columns
how to do responsive media queries and
stuff like that when you really read it
through it helps you understand how to
build your columns on your web page when
I started out I didn't know that in
every div container there are twelve
columns and reading that part made me
understand that now instead of having to
inspect my element every time I know
that if I were to build two comps it's
just automatically column and these six
column and e6 and so forth so it's like
reading your documentation really helps
you understand that and also once you
get your HTML CSS and those skills down
it'll help you understand JavaScript
more because you'll learn how to use Dom
elements and that's the key thing so
yeah really read your documentation
yeah well now eight months because I've
been in my job for about three and a
half months now but I got I actually got
my first job at my last module voce
coders bootcamp class so yeah you just
have to show oh I'm sorry sorry can you
see okay sorry okay so he said that when
you're a new developer what does your
company expect out of you when you first
started versus three months in so when
you first started they want you to get
to get familiar with their process of
working and also how they you know just
really focus on their software I'm not
sure how other jobs are but I know my
company we use a software where we
import all our code codes in and the
software was built by our lead senior
developer and so that's the main thing
is when you first started out is
learning how to use the software where
to place your header code where to put
place the footer where do you place your
link tags and everything in that where
do you place your JavaScript that's the
most important thing and then further
down the line progress is you know they
expect to see progress from you you know
stop putting inline styles in your HTML
start using CSS Morse start writing
multiple CSS to make the codes short and
clean and so from it's just really
building more and more experience seeing
not more experience I'm sorry just
seeing progress yeah yes
someone from twitch said what frameworks
in JavaScript you would like to use so
I'm really into react I want to get to
learn react more that's something I want
to eventually do but hopefully react and
angular is something I'm interested once
I get my jQuery down is okay yes he said
what skillset did I learn from star
space for the tech Lahoma
star space 46 is the organism that I
could apply to my job
honestly it's how to start out and find
a job like how to connect I got a lot of
ice from Kimberly - she's great she's
great I got advice from her on how to
build my resume she gave me a lot of
tips and then another person I'd like to
mention is Carmen she's helped me a lot
- and building my resume always linked
your github you know your portfolio on
top of your resume so that people can
see that the first thing that was
something I did that on my resume but I
linked to my portfolio in the back and
you don't want to do that smart to do in
the front so that everybody could see
and a lot is just like you know help
like debug learning how to use my
console that's what I learned and yeah
anybody else yes
currently I am building my friend's
wedding website right now it's good I
like it it's not the best but I like it
and that and then I cut out a
tic-tac-toe game yeah nothing to advance
but hey I'll get there you know you'll
get there I don't know if you're new in
my house okay well thank you so much
everyone Thank You Kimberly and check
Lahoma and everybody having me here
today I hope I could shed some light in
anybody though who wants to be a
developer make sure to practice practice
a lot for your dog mentation yeah